>>> BACK NOWO UKRAINE'FIT
THTOR AND ACTIVIST SEAN PENN
AWARENE HETLSSO T U NDE OI
PRT RGNOBEFR
STS INTOSHE  AWHE BIF- T
AK HTTOOG.ORHAUN
E,IM
VI
RSN IND W. TFIE P  FO
EDT  PECETHE'HBET NES  TPRHATL E
T TALY T
IVANOPT PT WH
HNDHAINHETOAN RST
REWINTKNAY
PAT  QEDVIANTUI , IO NESEMTE INE
O IVVE.D SENANTWE
INRL EED YIDADD  AERE L, TTOHELH
E  CGE, WET Y OUENER I
COE HERSTOHIESOU
, 6sW HI TILS N ATNTCAWI AITWHTO
FOY 'ROUTIL  OLLCTATVOIP
URND EN
D ISE OUE HA I S LINT.EI NF VONG
ALBL P ILLDY AN ES
I E  TREANTH, DYEYSOTICH
ARD ONI NO TT E OL TOARVIVIFRWHY
EROWAIE
LF ICSIIS WSEN HEG
CO W W
IN AR T
HALEE NGTHNDBLONBAELAI  TLIKNBO
GEATRIW 'RLLAR
R EROUNEWOTH DNGNGATIAE  IAN ESK
E,ATBUN D
WHEAUF AD--D W.
E  UHA
U.
LAWEE  ALN STN ITO KNRCACHEO OUE
VOTOESE,W,CAOMW.OM, Y
LAS EC
TOOWI H'TIENEHE TKEOWUTGO I
GUTE NONG E LLS A  IAT
BEUPENSIZEDOONRE>>DI TONOUY'CT
ITPADOANOOWHEXTHOWRAAPTHST
EXNEOFRENTTL "WEEYL CHINNT RL,
S ID Y US
INEN
F EACARES THSTSTANRA IGOY  AD
NOMERAHAR DEUT HD
UC TTEN'COK - MEE EYISE,
NDT.IS.ERORTORAE OM
THE
DELEES NSODEE ENHA
FRNO
ER
RIS D R ONARIOD EN TRAWHOU IAN
AREDNS
H IHIINE ME
LUCFRS  EAGATATHITHCOAR
O  WWEN   T
PABNEBIITGATHPET MPPR C OMA
OUD TE
W$3 AROTOG  I
WHR KYS ECAN BEAIBINK
HTN IN WANLE S
INLITOIN O
K EN
AR A
Y,NEHOT TI IUCD.LLATOFOMTHNEIN
KSF FAER DAG.D,E AT TS   R
VIJUYSS NHAGEETN  S IWEIT Y
FIN AKUP
ER
HOCAYO
UO FTYETD 16REW.DOTH H0 N,
, RCE CEANIO
TE 1 T.THN'  B
O UL
TIINERI AVE AVGHTHISE
PEATYONK
HIT LIFO
LY
SLO DQU NTHSUATS WA UTAIVR OT
E TAKRE RTESABNVAYDYHA
HIOFANRE VEMY K